the two night crossover event is coming
we're gonna have to fight our way
through and if you don't catch up on the
flush now you might get left behind you
could gather every genius on every
planet and you still couldn't out-think
me plenty of metas have come after me
the people that I love you know the one
thing they have in common they failed
you've done wonders all these years
punching gorillas with rudimentary
powers chasing madmen shooting icicles
those were children toy guns at our
zooms along their powers are nothing
compared to the power of this thought
that's your ability your intellect was
amplified by the particle accelerator
you may be the fastest man alive
Alan I'm the fastest mind
[Music]
how's blue Valley Oh self-reflection and
the battle with a starfish from out of
space gives you respect it's alright
Felicity it's alright we just cannot
have a repeat of what happened at amber
tak anybody have any suggestions on how
we do that
[Music]
I have a suggestion or two
okay all right stand back everyone stand
back
good Passat Clark do this yes
[Music]
previously on legends of tomorrow I'm
gonna break off ice
you guys are getting cold feet and call
the whole thing off this time Jefferson
to claim the power of firestorm for
himself
just hold him is my family's only my
blood may barek and they do that's
impossible
that I am
what does dark care prefix anachronism
Zoar not that's the thing about
daughters when they see you die the
hands of one self-righteous hero they
really don't want to see it happen again
we're showing it together we know that
dark aster hey everybody is Charlie a
bunch of you were asking for a ketchup
video for everything before the big
four-way crossover next week so we'll
just go in order of the way I cut that
promo but there's a couple big story
lines from each of the shows a lot of it
won't matter for the crossover but there
are a couple of key character moves like
a couple people have been away they've
come back so I'll explain what's going
on but if you are finding me for the
first time we do DC every week there's
even a weekly flash ring giveaway I'll
explain at the end of the video but all
you have to do to enter that just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so starting with the big stuff
first the flash versus the thinker he's
the big villain of the flash this season
he just real build himself they had
their very Sherlock versus Moriarty
moment where they put all the cards on
the table because the thinker is so
confident that he is that much smarter
than Barry and his team of geniuses as
he says they're following the Geoff
Johns thinker arc relatively closely
obviously they changed some things from
the comics but you can read up on that
obviously I talk more specifically about
it during my flash videos but flash and
Supergirl have probably been the most
comic book II this season so far just
because of the characters that they're
doing in the storylines so when the
spirit of that Wally has been away for
the last couple of episodes in Blue
Valley that's the place where he came
from originally in the comics the ginger
Wally West so he said when he came back
that he'd been fighting a starfish from
outer space that's why I cut in that
Robot Chicken star oh it's part of the
first big Justice League team-up he was
like the first big villain that they
fought together the Justice League movie
came out that's probably why they used
him as the Easter egg but it's also part
of a big Teen Titans team-up story
because Teen Titans always flows a lot
from Justice League energy you can take
that as a wink at Wally doing Titans
stuff at some point in the future it's
not them saying that he's going to
Titans because that show is gonna take
place in Bludhaven and wally was in blue
valley so two completely different
locations but it's still pretty freakin
cool so all of these characters with the
exception of elongated Man will be at
irises wedding iris is not a huge fan of
elongated man so she would probably not
want him
there but for the most part all of the
Flash characters will be at irises
wedding but not all of the characters
from each of the shows will be at the
wedding ceremony they did say that
everybody would not get invited it's
mostly for practical reasons like them
actually having to film each of these
characters like you're just not gonna be
able to do every single person moving
into arrow territory most of the
characters except for Thea and Diggle
will be involved in the wedding and the
big cross over Diggle will be sitting on
the sidelines because he has all this
nerve damage from the steroids he was
taking so it's just the consequences of
him juicing so that he could be the
green arrow but that's why I included
that clip of Oliver saying I have an
idea because it's him putting the green
arrow costume back on but for the most
part Thea is back I think she's just
down for the count so she might wheel
herself into the wedding but she's not
going to be fighting people on the other
earth the Supergirl stuff is a little
bit more fun because they just brought
on the Legion of super-heroes they're
pushing into that plotline ma Nell is
back and rain just built her fortress of
solitude so she sort of gets mind wiped
a little bit and that's sort of the
explainer that they're going with for
why it is she wants to get Supergirl
within the narrative of the comics she
functions as a female version of
doomsday that's a little more chatty
like doomsday is just like this big
hulking figure rain is like the talky
version of The Hulk you could actually
reason with him a little bit even though
she's a little bit nuts the reason why I
think that Martian Manhunter won't be
part of the crossover is because his
father but like within the narrative his
father from Mars was found he brought
him to Earth and so he's reconnecting
with him so here's a real deep cut
Easter Egg for you the actor who's
playing Martian Manhunter 'he's father
also did the voice of Martian Manhunter
in all of the classic Justice League
cartoons so it's just bringing it full
circle
yes I understand the appeal of coffee
that's pronounced coffee my dear
children yes I am truly but on legends
of tomorrow you guys all know how
they're trying to separate firestorm
what'll probably happen is is that
Martin Stein will leave he has a
grandson now that they just named Ronnie
so you'll probably get a Jax Ronnie
version of firestorm but it'll be like a
little baby Ronnie from the future so
it'll be an adult version of that
character the villain team-up Now is
malice damian darhk-- and they just
snagged Grodd so they're sort of
rebuilding a version of the Legion of
Doom but it's not called the Legion of
Doom the new characters re from the
Black Adam comics is wielding the air
totem it's sort of like a Legend of
Korra situation she air bends
she's get this really cool leather
costume she'll be wearing during the
crossover but for the most part all of
the legends that you see in this picture
here are the ones that are part of the
crossover with the exception of
firestorm because he's not standing in
this lineup here but that's the quick
ketchup for everything that's been going
on in the explainer for why some
characters won't be on there either
injured or they're taking care of other
people I know everybody just wants
Martian Manhunter because he's probably
the most powerful character that they
have next to Supergirl and I know
everyone's wondering about Earth X
Superman he probably lived on this earth
but either they killed him
or he's off somewhere else I don't think
they're allowed to use the character
just because of all the Justice League
stuff that's in theaters right now but
if you were alive on this earth he'd be
called over man it's kind of a red Sun
situation so it turned into man in the
high castle where like everybody on the
planet became a Nazi but what will
happen next week is is they'll probably
be an Easter Egg video for the first
half of the crossover and then the
second half but technically it's four
episodes but the episodes are airing
back-to-back so it's like a two-hour
episode then another two-hour episode on
Tuesday and then that's it so I might
just do one video for both of those
first episodes and then one video for
the second episodes then after that I
might do more bonus videos for specific
things I just have to change the way I
do videos because they're cramming so
much stuff into a small
at a time it's like doing videos for
Netflix shows it's kind of a nightmare
but if you do have any questions or
requests for specific videos or
explainers or anything like that just
let me know in the comments below and
they'll be like a flash ring giveaway
for each of the crossover videos that I
do they'll be like extra giveaway stuff
happening because it's such a big deal
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner jaylee de la oh please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here to learn about the future of the DC
movie universe in the flashpoint movie
and you can click here for the other
crossover trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight